GUY PODJARNY: Hi.
We've got Ilya Grigorik,
who's in developer
relations in Chrome.
And specifically has promoted
a lot WebP and, in general,
many, many different
performance topics.
So I'll let Kornel
introduce the topic here.
KORNEL LESINSKI: Hello everyone.
I'm going to start with
an obligatory HDV archive
statistic.
Since 2010 the amount of bytes
on a typical website used
for images has tripled.
And it'll probably
continue to grow
as larger and larger screens
become more affordable.
However, the situation is
not as terrible as it seems,
because average
connection speed is also
growing all across the board.
In the last three
years broadband speed
in United States has doubled.
And in China it has
more than tripled.
So on one hand if you
do absolutely nothing
with your images they'll load
faster by 20, 30% every year,
but on the other hand we'll
be using up all the bandwidth
that we possibly can.
Now looking on it
the other way, where
are those bytes coming from?
It's probably safe for web.
Adobe nailed this
interface 15 years ago.
And it's probably still
the most popular tool.
However, this is
a manual workflow.
It requires authors
to know specifics
of image formats,
which are the best,
and tune all the settings.
And as we get new image
formats, new optimizations,
the workflow becomes even
more tedious and complex.
Fortunately, new
tools are coming.
For example, Adobe
Generator can automatically
export all layers
of a Photoshop file
and optimize it
using latest tools.
There are also tools like
Mod_Page Speed or Akamai
front end optimization proxy
that will automatically
compress images optimized for
each browser specifically.
We have more new stuff.
The picture element now
in the latest browsers,
we can adapt images to screen
depth, screen size, aspect
ratio, and we can
also use new formats
with a graceful fallback.
HTP2 is going to make
delivery of images
really, really interesting.
With HTP1, browsers have
to delay image requests
to let CSS and
JavaScript load first.
However, in HTP2 the server
has control over this
and can send the first 5 or
10% of an image file that
contains image size and the
first progressive layer,
then let CSS load, then
send the rest of the data.
This way the browser, when
it does the very first line
layout, very first
paint of the page,
can already put some rough
version of the images in.
Next, new formats like the PNG.
It's been 17 years and
GIF is still doing great.
Why are we so bad at getting
rid of all the formats?
PNG with GIF-like
transparency worked
since IE4, that would be
like 147 Chrome versions ago.
And you might be thinking, oh
those are probably anim GIFs,
but, no.
With an average size of
just seven kilobytes,
all those GIFs, like a
quarter of images on the web,
could be replaced with a
better format already today
or 17 years ago.
Now the real, real new formats,
it's an interesting situation.
With dot WebP, which
is a very clever hack,
it's like one frame of a video
adopted into an image format,
so it's very good at
saving low quality images.
Google is promoting
the format very heavily
and is [INAUDIBLE] this.
However, other vendors
are still unconvinced.
Microsoft developed JPEG
extended range format, which
is aiming to be a
very high quality
format for digital cameras
that could potentially replace
the raw format in
digital cameras.
However, for the
use cases on the web
the compression is
not that impressive.
And Apple has been supporting
JPEG 2000 for a while.
The format itself is
as old as it seems.
And yet it failed to get
significant traction.
Arguments against
JPEG 2000 are the same
as arguments against
the other formats.
That is, anything
younger than 20 years
could be subject
to summary patents.
And the large corporations
that are already
harassed by patent controls
don't want to take extra risk.
Newer formats are more
computationally complex,
so could be slower to decode.
And, finally, it's
a matter of opinion
whether the gain of 20
or 30% of the file size
is worth the pain of adopting
the new format in all
the browsers, image editing
tools, image viewers,
native apps, and
everything else.
Mozilla has studied
some of the new formats
and they've concluded
it's not worth it.
They decided to stick
with JPEG, and improve
the compression of JPEG instead.
So most JPEG encoder
has been released.
It narrows the compression gap
a little bit with newer formats.
However, because of the
backwards compatibility,
it cannot add Alpha Channel.
It works with all browsers,
but its limited to what
JPEG can do already.
So for Alpha Channel we
have to resort to hacks
like lose.png encoders
or masking with SVG,
unless we have a newer format.
And there are even newer formats
that's like next generation
ahead, that maybe will
be in the future or not.
So H.264 is the most popular
video codec on the web today.
And its successor
could potentially
be used as a static
image format.
In tests it looks really good.
However, it's a non-free codec.
It's patented, so
it's a big problem
for open source software.
VP family of codecs is being
developed and extended.
And it's looking really well.
And there's an experimental
new codec from Xiph and Mozilla
called Daala.
But it's still too early to say
whether this will be successful
or not.
And a surprise.
JPEG extensions are
being worked on.
This is a way of
adding new features
to the old JPEG in a way that's
hidden from old decoders.
So the old browser will
see boring old JPEG.
But new browsers that
adapt the extensions
could support JPEG with Alpha
Channel, JPEG with better
dynamic range, and
all the new features.
And this work is
ongoing and could
be finished within a year.
So that's where
we are currently.
GUY PODJARNY: Thanks for that.
So I guess kicking off that,
the first question deals exactly
with these new image formats,
and one that's constantly
on my mind, which is, what's the
end game with these new image
formats?
Does one of these
formats prevail
and we all agree that it's
better than the others?
Do all browsers support
all the formats?
Or do we just need to
cope, to deal with it,
and learn to live with
this fragmentation?
I guess, maybe, Ilya,
I'll start with you.
I bug you about this
question every now and then.
Should Chrome support JPEG
XR and IE support WebP?
And have everybody
do everything?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Ideally
everybody would
implement every other's format.
There's a lot of
gotchas with doing that.
There's cyclical
reasons, there's
political reasons, anything
to do with patents.
It's a very complicated subject.
I think we need to get away
from trying to design one image
format that will rule them all.
And instead accept that
there is experimentation.
There will be different
formats to back.
Why is it so hard to
develop a new format?
Why did it take us 10 years
to deploy PNGs on the web?
That was a very painful process.
So what do we need to fix in
the ecosystem, in the platform,
in the browsers,
and everywhere else
to enable this sort of thing?
So there's gotchas with
deploying new formats,
like more fragmentation.
The developers have to deal
with all of these more settings.
I think a lot of that
can be automated.
So I don't think we're going to
see a future where everybody's
going to support
everybody else's format.
GUY PODJARNY: So you
think, basically,
to live with that fragmentation?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah, I think we
need to remove some barriers.
Today it's just very hard.
I think we're going to get
to some of the discussion
around saving different
formats, and what
happens when I can do
something in browser A,
but I can't do it in browser
B, and my operating system
can't preview it.
So we just need to
work out those kinks,
but I think once that's fixed,
it just becomes much easier.
GUY PODJARNY: And
Kornel, do you think
that when you look
out into the future,
one of these backward compatible
image formats is the way to go?
KORNEL LESINSKI: I
don't know the future,
but looking at the
web's past, you
can see that the
web is resisting
backwards incompatible changes.
So we had XHTML but
that didn't work.
Now we have HTML5
that they're built
on backwards compatibility.
XForms didn't catch on.
We had JPEG 2000 for a while.
That didn't catch on.
And GIF is still alive.
We have made a video
in the browser that's
15 times better than GIF
and hardware accelerated,
but anim GIFs are
still everywhere,
because they work everywhere.
So I think the existing formats,
even though they're technically
not the best, they have
a huge advantage because
of the network effect.
Because JPEG works everywhere.
We don't even realize
how much the pain there
is, that it has to be supported,
not only by top four browsers,
it has to be supported by
your desktop operating system,
by your mobile app, by
your Twitter client,
by the website where
you upload your avatar.
Those decoders have
to be everywhere.
GUY PODJARNY: So what's
the solution for that?
So we have that problem-- and I
guess Ilya you touched on this
as well-- do you think--
is it picture element,
and then kind of smarter--
YOAV WEISS: I think that the
picture mind switching use case
is part of the solution.
Another part of that would
be adding key header support
so that they accept header.
Assuming that all browsers will
publicize properly their newer
formats and their
access headers,
you could actually cache it
better using the key header.
And so yeah.
Hope for the best.
Hope that everyone
will converge.
And plan for the worst.
Plan for fragmentation.
GUY PODJARNY: So I think if
we're moving toward this as
if as we need to live with it,
because Chrome would always
try to go out-innovate
IE, and vice versa.
And also generally where
competition is good,
and it's moving us along.
Do you think that-- is
that realistic for somebody
building a website?
I mean, it's all good and well
on the technology front, but--
ANN ROBSON: Yeah.
I'd like to speak to
the question, which is,
will we have all these
different image formats,
or will one prevail?
And I think, I mean,
I agree that we
should be open to new formats
and support them and new ideas.
But Kornel's right.
We have these image formats
and they're like cockroaches.
You know GIFS, animated
GIFs, aren't going away.
And I think that we discovered
in the last few years
that we haven't
actually appreciated
what we've had quite enough.
And that JPEG is actually
a really good image format.
And there's a lot
we can do with JPEG.
So I feel like we should
probably respect it a bit more.
It's a 20-year-old format,
but-- what is it Kornel?
I think somebody was
calling it the alien
from the future, or something?
KORNEL LESINSKI: Alien
technology from the future.
Yes.
ANN ROBSON: Yeah.
KORNEL LESINSKI: That
quote is in a context
of how hard it is to beat
JPEG, even though it's
an old format
designed for computers
that had 25 megahertz CPUs.
Now we have codecs designed for
computers with gigahertz CPUs,
and we're not beating JPEG by
a large margin, maybe 20, 30%,
maybe 40% in very expensive,
experimental codecs.
But we don't have a format
that is 10 times better.
So for its age, JPEG
really nailed compression.
GUY PODJARNY: Can we
get a mic to Jack?
ANN ROBSON: And I think
that's really important.
Because we have JPEG
and we can improve it.
So I think that-- what is it?
Mozjpeg is there.
Mozilla is actually working on
improving the JPEG encoding.
And I don't think anybody has
done this for a long time.
We have just had
JPEG and we haven't
thought about improving what
we have and what already works.
So that's something
that we should focus on.
I do want to have
all these good ideas,
and have people creating
new image formats,
and try to support
them, and figure out
ways we can support them.
But at the same time,
we want to move forward
and we haven't moved forward
with image formats very much.
So I feel like we should think
about what's important to us,
and agree on that,
and move forward.
And I think that-- sorry
for taking so much time-- I
think that one of the things
that's important to me
is progressive scans.
I think that the image
format that we invest in,
that we spend our time talking
about, and implementing,
and serving, should be one
supports progressive scans.
GUY PODJARNY: If you
can stand up for the AV.
AUDIENCE: So speaking from
a browser point of view,
I agree with Ilya,
that we're never
going to see full support
across all the browsers for all
these different formats.
But I don't see why
they really need
to if we can somehow figure
out a way for a new element,
or something like that, to
basically-- you just say,
here's the resource that I want,
regardless of some extension
on the end of it.
And just have the browser send
along its accepted abilities,
of what it can have
returned to it.
Is that something that
is on the horizon?
Or is that something
that anybody's
had interest in doing?
YOAV WEISS: It's already here.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah,
so that exists.
That's content negotiation.
And you send an accept
header that's says,
I support these formats.
And the server then
picks the right format,
the optimal format, perhaps,
for that particular client.
So that works today.
You can--
AUDIENCE: Is it for a
specific content [INAUDIBLE]?
Like I could get WebP
versus JPEG and [INAUDIBLE]?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes.
Yes, so that works today.
Chrome will send an
accept header that says,
I support WebP.
So in fact, that's how we
recommend you deploy WebP.
And now you can also use
Picture where you can manually
specify all the
different variants,
if you're willing to do that.
GUY PODJARNY: So just maybe
to push back a little bit--
so Kornel, you pointed out, hey
it's just 20 to 30% percent,
but image bytes on the
web have grown by two
or three-fold in just
two or three years.
And for all indications,
generally, that trajectory
is up and to the right.
Saving 20 or 30% is not
an insubstantial amount.
Should somebody make
an effort, if we're
doing all these
different-- if we're
going towards the
path of fragmentation,
is it worthwhile?
KORNEL LESINSKI: It's
a matter of trade offs.
I don't think new format will
advance the industry by one
year, because the connection
speeds grow by 20, 30% so--
GUY PODJARNY: Arguably--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KORNEL LESINSKI:
With new format we
can do this year what we would
be able to do anyway next year.
So I think if we're looking
for a completely new format we
should also look for something
that current formats completely
cannot do.
Because what we have
is the same thing
we had 20 years ago,
but better compressed.
But how about new formats
that support different kinds
of Alpha Channel that
can do attitude blending,
like all the blending
modes in Photoshop,
or hybrid pixel vector formats.
ANN ROBSON: Also, I think
that also stereo images.
We never do 3D or
think about 3D,
but our eyes are actually
seeing different pictures
all the time.
Why not support
this in the future?
Stereo cameras may become
a big hit in a year.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it's
also a little bit of,
maybe, push back on, the
bandwidth is increasing
and hence everything
will be solved.
That's not entirely
true, because bandwidth
is only one part of it.
We still have the round trips.
And those round trips can
only carry so much data.
So even the fact that you
have the latest LTE connection
on your phone, doesn't mean
you can just push a 10 megabyte
image immediately.
GUY PODJARNY: Yeah.
Right.
Also we have
[INAUDIBLE] which is--
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
In fact, a 10 megabit connection
is but one megabyte a second.
So it'll take a second
to download that image.
And according to some of the
best practices that we're
pushing, we're saying that your
page should load in one second.
So what about all
the other resources?
So I don't think
it's completely fair.
It's certainly true that
as bandwidth is increasing,
but that's not really
enough of a justification
to say these 20,
30% don't matter,
and these two things will
always go up at the same rate.
GUY PODJARNY: Let's try to move
to the next question, which
is actually along these lines.
So let's say we want to live
with these different multiple
image formats, what
do you think-- well I
guess I'll read the question.
Given the need to serve a
different image depending
on factors like
displays, so small screen
to small image to
small screen, browser
capabilities for
the image formats,
network conditions,
potentially lower
quality image in poor
condition, should we
be advocating for
different URLs for all
of these different situations?
Or for one dynamic
URL that adjusts?
And, I guess, if the latter,
what's the right approach?
Is it picture?
Is a client negotiation?
YOAV WEISS: Ideally, I would
say the best approach is
the approach that works
for the developer that's
maintaining the website.
Currently there are problems
with the single URL approach,
mostly related to
caching, mostly related
to lack of key support.
So this is something we will
have to work on in order
to enable cache-able
single URL images.
But after that it depends on--
it's a development preference.
GUY PODJARNY: Yeah, but
still, what do we recommend?
Everything depends.
There is no golden answer.
But should we try to advocate
towards pushing people
towards one dynamic URL
and to put the effort
behind that key header?
Or should we be advocating
towards the picture element?
YOAV WEISS: I think
we should enable both
because the use
cases are different.
A single URL means you have
a smart backend CDN module,
something that you control
on the server side that
pushes the right format
to the right browser.
Multiple URL gives the
control to site's author.
So you can do that.
You can basically support
multiple image formats
and mark up.
These are different audiences.
GUY PODJARNY: So you think
we have to have them both?
YOAV WEISS: I think
we have to have both.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I think the
practical answer is, today
if you want to make it work
and work well, you probably
have to end up erring on
the side of dedicated URLs.
Just because your infrastructure
in between your CDN,
your whatever, is
not configured,
is not flexible enough
to allow all of that.
But I would like
to fix that such
that we move towards
the world where
you don't have to do that.
You don't have to have
a unique URL for each--
you have to have a 100 URLs
for the same damn image,
because one happens to be
in a different format, one
the scale is set
slightly different,
one is cropped this
way or that way.
GUY PODJARNY: Why is that?
I mean, what do you think
is the primary motivation,
I guess, for having one URL
versus-- like today we're
used to having one URL and we
don't need that complexity to
[INAUDIBLE].
ILYA GRIGORIK: To me
it's just automation.
I just want to move the world
towards more automation.
I shouldn't have to
think about negotiating
the right image based on DPR.
We have to do that today.
And I think in the
long term, that's
just too much complexity.
YOAV WEISS: Yeah, you can also
automate it with a build step,
assuming-- but I think we agree.
ANN ROBSON: Oh, just that I
think that we'd screw it up.
We wouldn't do it quite right
if we did ourselves, and, yeah.
GUY PODJARNY: So
you think we should
strive towards that single
URL, but we should also
have automated tools,
have a generator,
or make some
decisions, or help us
make the decisions
about which image
to send at any given time.
ANN ROBSON: Yes.
ILYA GRIGORIK: We're already
doing a lot of the stuff
by encoding.
Any sizable applications
already has an image resizing,
manipulation-something server.
You have one source of
origin, or source of truth,
and then that one thing
gets rescaled to all
the different variants.
And right now we end up
encoding a lot of information
in the URL, even though
a lot of that metadata
is already available in an
image tag or the picture tag.
Because you're saying,
my width is this,
then you duplicate the
width in the URL as well.
We can just get rid
of a lot of that,
just make it much simpler.
GUY PODJARNY: Well,
if I can actually
pull in something from a
question we had further down.
I mean, if we do
that when we talk
about multiple
image and one image,
one use case that
comes to mind is
the notion of a single URL that
can be fetched by any client.
And then maybe
subsequently opened
by your operating system
and things like that.
If we focus for now on
sharing a link on Twitter
and having anybody be
able to [INAUDIBLE].
Do you think that that basically
eliminated the possibility
of making it be
picture element based?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So
this-- can I jump in?
This is actually a good argument
against having a dedicated URL.
So let's say you have a
dot JPEG, and a dot WebP,
and a dot something else.
And the dot WebP is only
configured to serve WebP.
I see that because I accessed
that thing in my browser
that understands WebP.
I copy that.
I paste it into my email.
And then you open it in
some other browser and you--
what then?
You can't open it.
Now it's a broken image.
So really that URL, even
though it says it's a dot WebP,
needs to understand
the fact that there
are other clients that may
not understand it and serve
a different asset.
So we're back to
the same one URL.
GUY PODJARNY: So
given that, why do
we need MIME type
decision in picture?
YOAV WEISS: You could
also, for example,
have the browser expose,
save shareable link--
expose the JPEG URL
when sharing stuff.
Exposed the-- You can Save As
even though you view the WebP.
If you're doing Save As,
save as a sharable format
you're saving to disc as JPEG.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So Save As is a
little bit of a different case
though.
So I agree.
Now we're into the discussion
of save a safe version.
Whatever that means.
And perhaps this is something
that browsers should
do, like you viewing this
thing in whatever format,
and when you're right
clicking and doing Save As,
should we give you a PNG?
It may be not good for
size, but at least it
preserves the quality and
you can open it everywhere.
Should we do that?
Maybe.
Maybe not.
That doesn't really address the
sharing of a copy of the URL
and paste it into email.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
YOAV WEISS: --copy the URL.
Yes, I agree.
This is a downside.
GUY PODJARNY: Let's take a
thought from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Is this on?
So in regards to having a
single URL and it not working
if you copied to
another-- if you
go to WebP in Firefox,
or IE, or whatever--
isn't that true of any
proprietary format though?
It was pushed like MHTML
formats didn't work in Chrome
for the first 10
versions of Chrome,
although they
always worked in IE.
Why is that just because
something doesn't work,
why is that necessarily
a bad thing?
And how is that-- so if I
try and Coral that image
and there's no content
negotiation automatically
in Coral without that,
what would you serve?
Or how does that fit into this
when you want a single URL?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So you're right.
It's nothing new.
I don't think that's a
good experience overall,
because people tend to
like to share photos and--
ANN ROBSON: Exactly.
That's all.
I mean, people get pissed off.
They're just going to
get angry at your site,
at the site that provided this
image that they couldn't share
the way they're used to sharing.
KORNEL LESINSKI: It
just has to work.
Plus having one URL for
negotiation off the format
might actually be the easiest
option for the developer
if they install some
kind of a server side
software like Mod_Pagespeed that
will just do it automatically.
So this is good for users
because URLs just work.
This is the best in
terms of bandwidth,
because every browser will
get the best format it can.
And it's convenient
for the developer,
because they just put
one format on the server,
it could be even a PNG, and then
don't worry about compression.
GUY PODJARNY: Should
we-- can we get a mic
to wesbrock and Lucas.
And in the meantime, it's worth
noting to highlight a point
that Yoav made before, that
we do need to handle caches.
And that if we are going to have
a single URL that's dynamic,
it's important
that we make sure,
whether it's your CDN, or
your server side caches,
or whatever, support
that type of flexibility.
GUY PODJARNY: Can
we just-- sorry--
sorry let me just take a--
YOAV WEISS: Just
one second point.
We have had the same situation
for video for a while.
So I don't know if this is
a big problem for video,
but it's the same problem.
AUDIENCE: I really
like this concept
of having the Save As
attach to a different file,
that you can source after you're
starting with a dynamic URL,
because we've been talking
so far about the developer,
and the developer
facing the end user.
But one thing that we
haven't been talking about
has been the content creator.
And if I'm talking
about my friend's image
that he took in Cabo,
maybe it doesn't really
matter if all of the
attributions and metadata
that we're pulling
out of that file
to make our website's
performance is attached.
But if this is a
Nobel winning image.
It just came straight
out of Pulitzer's.
You're going to want to
keep all of that metadata
when someone saves
it, because you're not
going to lose that attribution.
So just in support
of the single URL
allowing you to have multiple
options, because then you
get to serve all three, if
not more, constituencies.
GUY PODJARNY: Can we get Lucas?
He has been waiting for--
KORNEL LESINSKI: So in
the meantime, actually
single URL for the
use case of metadata
is not that helpful, because
we don't have any way
to tell browser when
you want the version
with metadata or without.
Maybe that's something actually
for the picture element,
where you could specify
different resolutions,
some for the web and
some special version
that's original, or lossless
or metadata-rich one.
ILYA GRIGORIK: But
you could tackle
that with the same mechanisms.
Because basically what
you're asking for is,
you have an asset, you want
to right-click and use--
or just Save As.
And in your except
header you could
advertise, I want the
full fidelity thing,
whatever that means.
Perhaps your proxy re-sized
it to my view-port.
I want the full thing.
I want the high
resolution image.
GUY PODJARNY: Let me take
the two, Lucas and Mark,
and then we'll move
on to the next topic.
AUDIENCE: So content
negotiation is not a new thing.
And the ability to
have a single URL
has been around for probably
10 years, I imagine.
And in my experience
it's tough sledding
to sell that to a
development team.
So I think there's
a lot of elegance
to content negotiation, or the
idea of having a single URL,
that it presents
itself differently.
But I think that's a
dedicated project that
probably needs to be taken on.
I imagine Mark
Nottingham, for example,
and other people who have gotten
close to the problems there.
But it's a separate issue.
I think that the web developer
community has spoken clearly
against it.
I don't quite understand
why, because I
appreciate the elegance of it.
But I think the voice of
the developer community
is pretty clear.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I'm not
convinced by that argument
because we have GZIP.
And you don't upload a dot
HTML dot GZ, or CSS dot GZ.
That's content negotiation.
There is a GZIP version
and some other version.
It's the same thing as saying,
here's a PNG which is high
fidelity, versus
a compressed JPEG.
So it works.
We use it every day.
I think there are
problems in our facts,
in terms of the caches, and all
the rest, where we don't have
enough granularity to be
able to precisely target
particular assets.
So we end up doing
things like oh, vary on
accept, but the
accept header happens
to be this very highly
fragmented-- or high entropy
string, which basically
fragments the cache.
So we got to fix those things.
That's what Yoav was referencing
by the key stack, which
is something that
Mark is working on.
GUY PODJARNY: Let me take Mark.
One last note, and
then we're really
way over time on this one.
AUDIENCE: So-- oh jeez.
Yeah, I think 10 years ago,
15 years ago the community
was fairly anti, but I
think I agree with Ilya.
The tools are getting there.
There's a lot more
intermediaries doing things
with [INAUDIBLE].
It's getting easier.
My question was about key.
It sounds like you guys were
depending on it, more or less.
It's not done.
And there are actually some
hard problems inside of it.
But we've also not seen a lot
of browser interest in it yet.
I need browser
engagement by those guys.
And we need to
actually implement.
Unless Yoav pulls this trick
again and raises 15 grand,
somebody needs to go
and write the code.
GUY PODJARNY:
That's a fair point.
I'm actually going
to pause here,
because we're almost
two questions in there.
Let's talk about the next one.
So when we look at these
different image formats,
it seems like every entity
has their own different image
formats.
So came the question
from Patty, when
will we have a test benchmark
for image performance?
And if we have that,
what should it include?
ANN ROBSON: No good reason.
Definitely, we should
have a benchmark
for image performance.
I think that we should have a
benchmark for image compression
as well.
We don't even have a-- well
I guess we do, the Lenna.
There's this image that
people use from 1973.
So I think that we
could update this.
And we need to understand
what these lossy image
formats do to our image.
So I think that we should
have a set of images
that we use that are good
examples of how images get
degraded when they get encoded.
So we should do that, and then
also for image performance,
definitely.
We should think about that.
When we're considering
these things
we should figure out
exactly what we need.
GUY PODJARNY: Let's take,
actually, Jonas's opinion
and then go back to panel.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was actually-- when
we were on the
first topic, I was
going to suggest
exactly this, that one
of the big reasons Mozilla
has not gotten behind WebP
is that there
plainly disagreements
about how much better
is compared to JPEG.
And I have no idea who
is right about this.
But I think having a benchmark
that people can agree
is sort of representative
of today's web,
would provide a lot more
information than what
we have to go on right now.
Because people just disagree
on how many percent better
is this versus that.
And this is not just
WebP versus JPEG,
it's between all
of these formats.
GUY PODJARNY: What
would you include?
So in that debate back then, one
of the, for instance, questions
was around whether you should
use the existing images
on the web as the
source, or whatever
it is you were
going to encode to,
versus the pristine image that
might have been your original.
Maybe there are other debates.
What would you include
in that type of image?
And that type of a benchmark?
AUDIENCE: I think
compare-- I think
what you want to do-- the
thing that actually matters
is how fast can you
download, and the image that
is being displayed
in the browser.
I don't care how
you can compress
that the 10 megabyte
original image,
and how much smaller
you can make that.
What actually matters is that
the smaller images that we
downloaded and render on web
pages, how many bytes smaller
can we make them?
One of the really
hard things is there
are four different ways of
measuring image quality.
And I have no idea what the
different algorithms are.
I don't know if we need
to measure all of them
in this benchmark, or if we
just need to as a community
agree on one or two
that are sort of more
representative for what the
human eye actually appreciates.
But I think that having a
discussion around what we
should actually measure,
because a bad benchmark--
this something we see lot in
JavaScript-- a bad benchmark
can do just as much harm
as a good benchmark.
GUY PODJARNY: Now, Kornel,
you deal with this.
You benchmark your own
tools all the time.
KORNEL LESINSKI: Yes,
that's a big problem
for my work on PNG compressors.
Although there are standard test
suites for photo-like images
there's popular
codec image suite.
There is no test
suite that includes
Alpha Channel for images.
So for testing how well
Alpha Channel compresses,
I have to steal
images from the web.
But this is not a set of images
that I could share with anybody
to let them compare
their results with mine.
There's also a big problem
of judging actual quality.
So we have machine algorithms
that sort of emulate
how the eyes see
distortions in images,
but this is very imperfect.
But it's also very sensitive.
The algorithm can detect
a half a percent change
in image quality,
which is needed
when you're
developing your codec.
When you tweak something and
make it half percent better,
you want to keep that change.
But if you ask a human, is
that half percent better
than the other image, they
will not be able to tell you.
GUY PODJARNY: Which
is similar to the,
which algorithm do
we use for quality?
What's the bar?
What's the threshold?
KORNEL LESINSKI:
Yes, and since there
are different implementations of
different approximations of how
people judge quality, there
are different opinions.
And if you use one
algorithm, then
somebody developing a
different codec will tell you,
no you've used the
wrong algorithm.
You should be benchmarking
using my algorithm on my images.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I think this
is also one of the reasons
why we have so much disagreement
in all the different formats,
is because everybody
uses their own test set.
So when we say images,
do we mean photos?
High res photos?
Do we mean the PNGs,
and the Alpha Channel,
and all the rest?
GUY PODJARNY: And animated GIFs.
ILYA GRIGORIK:
And animated GIFs.
Right.
So one of the things that the
WebP team has been pushing
for all time is, we always say
we're optimized for the web.
In the sense that, we try
to grab images off the web
as they are being
used today, not just
a bunch of really high def
raw formats off my camera.
That's a use case.
That's a totally
valid use case, that
is not representative
of the entire web.
And we try to
optimize for those.
In fact, we see a lot
better compression and gains
on the long tail
of weird images.
The stuff we put
in PNGs is bizarre,
KORNEL LESINSKI: Yeah.
The problem for me is, I
don't run Google Images,
so I don't have
access to that set.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Well,
we don't actually
have good access
to that set either.
But one idea would
be to say, great,
let's go to [INAUDIBLE] archive,
download all the images,
and just re-compress all of
them with our algorithms.
But then you
discover that you're
re-compressing artifacts
of other formats.
So really, ideally we
would have the origin
or the original asset.
And then we would have
a test against all
the different formats.
But that's very hard to come by.
YOAV WEISS: That's one of the
criticisms I heard regarding
WebP, the fact that current
numbers are achieved
by re-compressing,
introduce their own bias,
and their own artifacts.
So--
ILYA GRIGORIK: So,
and this is funny,
because we actually had this
really long discussion--
the WebP team with
the Google+ team--
that they really
care about photos.
They want to deliver
really beautiful photos.
And at one point
we found that we
were talking to the
product managers,
effectively trying to replicate
JPEG compression artifact.
The formats are different.
You're going to get
different artifacts.
But they really liked
the JPEG artifacts.
GUY PODJARNY: Which once again--
ILYA GRIGORIK:
Because it's like,
that's what we're
used to seeing.
But look this is so--
GUY PODJARNY: Similarity.
Do you need to be
similar to the original,
or similar to the codec?
Let's take Wesley's point.
AUDIENCE: Can you hear me?
There we go.
Going back to the comment
that was made earlier
about file size,
does that really
matter when the decoder
may take longer,
say for the instance
WebP versus JPEG?
WebP's going to take
longer to decode
that image based
on the CPU and what
system resources
that computer has.
So how do you get a benchmark
for that kind of performance
and are you guys
concerned about that?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
So definitely a big concern.
So in speaking about WebP,
it's definitely an area
that we're looking to improve.
So we're lending new incremental
decoding improvements
and all the rest.
There is hardware support
that will come down the road.
It's kind of a chicken
and egg problem.
And despite that, we do see
that when we run test studies--
eBay actually did
a study where they
converted all their
images to WebP.
And they compared decoding
time versus the delivery time.
Because the images were shipped
much faster, even though you're
decoding it longer, they
still showed up faster.
So you can quantify
these things.
You can use something like,
see how much of the image
is rendered at each point in
time and-- It is quantifiable.
GUY PODJARNY: Let's get
David's point and move
to the next topic.
David.
AUDIENCE: I guess
the one other thing
to think about is that there's
this final size versus quality
trade off.
And what these new
formats are doing
is sort of very
slightly shifting
that curve in the file size
versus quality trade off.
But I guess the other question
the developers, I think,
should think about is, are
they at the right point
on that curve.
Are people making the
file size versus quality
trade off that they
want to be making?
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes.
OK.
This is a big topic and
an under-explored topic.
So we're pushing new formats
that are getting 10, 15, 20,
30% improvement in file size.
But there is the other side
of this equation, which
is all those formats have
the quality slider, which
the developers and designers
are just not using.
Because we don't have
the right tooling
to expose that sort of thing.
And it's like a quality
40 or 50 on a WebP
is completely different
from a quality 50 on JPEG.
In fact, it's a
different output,
even if you use different
JPEG compressors.
Each one introduces
its own artifacts.
So I think we could
do way, way better job
by providing some better tooling
and visualization to when
you're saving these
images, or automation.
How do you find the right
point on that curve, where
the trade off between
how much the image has
degraded versus savings.
YOAV WEISS: The
thing is there are--
I'm not sure we have
the ideal tools,
but we have tools like image
men that Kornel worked on.
It was based on some
previous metric.
He added SM, which is more
standard image visual metric,
in order to just binary
search is the ideal quantity.
So a developer can define,
I want a 5% quality loss,
or something much
more quantifiable
than the quality
setting which is--
GUY PODJARNY: We're
kind of going over.
But I think that
actually shows up.
We can probably discuss
this a little bit more
in the next question,
which is, what
should be our
strategy for managing
these multi-resolution images.
So a part of it is about,
maybe, just the image,
the straight tooling.
But as dealing with that
image becomes more complex,
as we mentioned before already
a certain bias in favor
of automation, if we're going
to use the single URL, what
should be the strategy?
Should people try
and pre-generate
these ahead of time?
Because a lot of these tools
around the binary search,
for instance, are very hard
to do real time, or not
practical at all sometimes
to do in real time.
What's the right move?
Kornel, what do you
think about that?
KORNEL LESINSKI: So generating
multiple resolution images
by hand is super boring.
So we definitely,
definitely should
have tools that automate this.
And when we have a tool
that automatically generates
different sizes,
we can no longer
ask the author to tweak this
quality slider themselves.
So I want to completely
eliminate the quality slider
from all [INAUDIBLE] for images.
It's a complete lie.
It's not actual
quality you're getting.
It's just arbitrary
mathematical formula
for throwing away bits
of data from the file.
And it makes some
files ugly, some files
can tolerate more compression.
And we should use CPU
power that we have,
algorithms that we to try
to get the right quality.
Even if the algorithm
is not perfect,
it's probably still going to
be better than many authors who
have their favorite
number they always
use for all their images.
GUY PODJARNY: Ann, what
would you want to do?
What's your optimal-- you
need to support these 17
different variants images and
optimize them in your site.
ANN ROBSON: I mean, automatic.
I'm not going to
do that by hand.
GUY PODJARNY:
Automatic real time?
Or automatic build time?
Like automatic in the delivery?
ANN ROBSON: Yeah, I am not sure.
I think probably in delivery.
Although it'd be nice
to check them, right?
I think that's
amazing what Kornel
is saying, that we should
get rid of the sliders.
I mean, he's saying that.
He saying we should
get rid of the quality
sliders in our images
that we're optimizing.
Wow.
I think that's right.
I think we as humans-- the
numbers are magic numbers
that we come up with, don't
work for all of the photos.
And that maybe we can
automatically figure out
what's the best,
exactly the best
quality, to set a
certain photo at.
That's cool.
GUY PODJARNY: I
think I cut you off
before Yoav, but [INAUDIBLE].
YOAV WEISS: I think that
the question of offline
versus online-- so offline will
always get you better ratios,
but you can't always do that.
So offline when you can,
and otherwise-- I mean,
even if you compress on the fly,
you should probably cache it,
and you should probably
try to re-compress
the original after the fact.
But we're talking about
fairly complex back end, but--
As we said, the image mend
stuff, the binary search,
re-compress the image multiple
times, that's CPU consuming.
That's not something
you can do on the fly.
GUY PODJARNY: Let's take
a question from Mark.
AUDIENCE: So I just
wanted to provide
a little color for that.
We do generate a photo-shelter.
We deal with a lot
of image delivery
from very high resolution
files to non-lossy files,
raws, et cetera.
And we have to generate
web-friendly versions.
So we do do the image
variants multi res on the fly.
But I just want to tie together
with the previous compression
discussion and how difficult
it is to benchmark.
And even with algorithmic
ways to analyze quality,
it doesn't really
capture the subjective,
the perceptual aspect of it.
And we basically change our
image pipeline, not too often,
every few years.
But when we do it
takes a whole year
to decide what trade
offs are worthwhile.
And we did find
that this question
about JPEG quality--
we're using JPEG.
We're not using
any-- because it's
the only thing that
works universally.
But it gets complicated, because
with the multi-resolution,
and also the compression,
the rescaling,
they are all interactive.
So we have found that
actually that doing
that file size and quality trade
off depends on also the size
that you're
delivering the image.
That actually on a
larger resolution image
you can get away with
more compression and kind
of counterbalance.
So I think that is very
important, obviously.
I'm not saying that any
of these image formats
are trying to be
prescriptive, but you can only
get so far trying to optimize
the algorithm and the format.
Because you need to leave
a certain amount of control
to the developer and
the delivery mechanism.
Because we did find that we have
to fine tune it significantly.
And now with high
DPI displays, now you
can get away with even more
compression to deliver even
a larger asset, that's
not perceptually relevant.
So that's just a
little feedback.
GUY PODJARNY: OK.
Thanks.
That's good input.
So we only have a
few more minutes,
let me actually skip
a couple questions
and switch to the crystal
ball question at the end.
Which is, one of the reasons
for the growth of images
has been retina displays, and
now we have a batch of new 3X,
or kind of 3X
screens, which Android
has been doing in
iOS, which Android
has been doing for awhile.
What would you guess,
I guess-- what's
your prediction for the future?
Are we done at the 2, 3X?
Is there ever a done component
of their virtual reality
of 3D images?
You had an opinion
about this before.
ANN ROBSON: Yeah, my
opinion was I don't care,
because we're not doing what
we can right now with 2X.
So I think that
at a certain point
we can't really
tell the difference.
Like there's not going to be
such a jump from 2X to 3X.
It's not really going to be 3X.
I don't think that-- I
think that-- I don't know--
I'm on the side delivering
worse images faster,
than delivering perfect images.
GUY PODJARNY: It's
not about the density
but more about, we need
to educate our users
to try to get progressive image.
First get something then--
ANN ROBSON: Definitely.
Definitely.
Let's focus on that first.
But I think it's exciting.
I'd love to see a high
retina image on the web.
I think it's really beautiful.
But I'm not sure how much
more we could push it.
GUY PODJARNY: And Kornel, did
have some opinions on this?
KORNEL LESINSKI: Well, we
are upgrading our displays,
but we're not
upgrading our eyes yet.
And the eyes are the
ultimate benchmark.
So I think--
GUY PODJARNY: We should
work on upgrading our eyes.
KORNEL LESINSKI: Yes, we
should go for cyborgs.
But before that, I think
we'll settle on something
like 2X or 3X, because it
just doesn't make any sense
to put more pixels.
GUY PODJARNY: What do
you think Ilya of that?
ILYA GRIGORIK: If I remember
the marketing correctly,
retina was supposed
to be defined
as you can see the
difference anymore.
So when they come up with retina
HD, and you're just like--
can't see the difference.
GUY PODJARNY: But practically
speaking, that's fine for us,
maybe, performance
nerds here saying that.
But the reality is
that they did shift 3X
and would they shift 4X?
And would our designers insist
that they want to use those?
YOAV WEISS: I think we need
data on how much of a difference
does it make if we send
out 2X images, to 3X,
4X whatever-X displays,
and have hard data so
that if the designers
come with 4X images,
we can throw them out the door.
And there was at
Velocity last week--
this week-- research regarding
that progressive JPEGs that
was done, basically, by
looking at how people react
to images displayed
on the screen.
And regardless of the result,
which is somewhat surprising,
I think we need to do the same
for contentiously bad images.
What happens if we display
1X images on a 3X display?
How bad is it, as far
as user experience goes?
Same for 2X images, et cetera.
We need data.
GUY PODJARNY: We need
to switch to the data.
Yeah, the results there
were not favorable
of progressive images,
despite everybody's hypothesis
in the room ahead of time.
So I think-- OK we still
have five more minutes.
So I misestimated
the times here.
So I guess we switch
to Andrew's question
from here, which is those
are all technical questions,
but if we talk a little bit
about a use case question.
Move one back.
How important is
it that an image
format we use on
a website is one
that a user can save and
view in a different spot.
I mean, we touched
this a little bit
because we talked
about the multi URL,
so they can open it
everywhere, but does it
matter that the OS
gets into the display?
Or are we done with browsers?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So
I think it really
depends on the use case of it.
Ideally, it should be viewable.
So if I save it, I
should be able to view it
with whatever software
that I have, by default.
That would be nice.
We do have some
examples where that
doesn't appear to be a problem.
So, for example,
Opera and Chrome,
we have the compression
proxies, which
have been transcoding all
images WebP for years.
And users are happy.
And as far I'm aware I have
not heard anybody scream
about saving out
images as WebPs,
which is what you would get.
Because if you don't have a the
safe save, or something else.
So that's an example.
There are plenty
of big sites that
also use WebP, eBay,
OKCupid, all those sites.
It doesn't appear
to be a problem.
Is that a good answer?
I'm not convinced
that it is, but--
GUY PODJARNY: But you
don't think it's blocker.
ILYA GRIGORIK: No.
GUY PODJARNY: You think our
primary conversations should
remain in browser-land
and the OS would catch up.
ILYA GRIGORIK: If
your use case actually
involves downloading an image,
you have a photo gallery
and an actual "save as"
is not a right click--
I'm not even sure how many
like nontechnical users know
to right click and "save as."
They're probably fishing
for the Download button
somewhere in the UI.
That button should
do something smart,
like not save the
fancy new format.
It should save the safe format.
Can browsers do a better job?
Probably.
GUY PODJARNY: And Ann
do you think that when
you deal with the social
sharing platform--
ANN ROBSON: Yeah, I
think it's very important
to be able to not
break the image.
But yeah, and I think
Ilya was getting
on something really
kind of interesting.
It depends on what
kind of site you have.
If you have your
own photo gallery,
I think it's important
for you to be
able to "save as" right
click, drag to your desktop.
There's kind of cool hack I
think only with Chrome where
when you drag to
your desktop you
can deliver a different
high res image.
That's kind of cool.
But yeah, definitely.
I don't like the idea.
I love right clicking.
I love like taking images
offline and sharing them.
GUY PODJARNY: So
it's important to be
able to do the Save As
we talked about before,
but then if you'd need to
convert to something that's
a little bit more universal.
ANN ROBSON: Yes.
KORNEL LESINSKI: But
people do share images.
They remics images.
All your LOLCat images, they
were saved from somewhere.
So WebP can work
as sort of a DRM
for photos, where you
save it to desktop,
and then you try to open it.
Oh you don't have
the right plug in.
GUY PODJARNY: Can we
get Margaret a mic?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I work on Firefox for Android.
And we actually
have UI telemetry
to see what people
use in the browser.
And actually the Save
Image context menu,
in Firefox at least, is one
of the highest menu items
that people use.
And we kind of wonder
what kind of images
they're saving necessarily.
But I just want to
throw out that data.
That we do have data that
people use that a lot
so you probably wouldn't
want to break that.
ANN ROBSON: Excellent.
GUY PODJARNY: Interesting.
YOAV WEISS: So safe
sharing, safe saving
should probably be a thing.
Either for client side markup
picture-based multiple images,
or for server side, because
we can play with the except
headers.
ANN ROBSON: I think
that this panel actually
has an action item.
GUY PODJARNY: I think
there are good items.
So we talked about--
I think we agreed
that we want a single
URL, not multiple images,
that we need to create
a test benchmark,
although we haven't talked
about how we actually
go about doing that-- one
that everybody agrees upon.
KORNEL LESINSKI: So maybe if
you have really good images that
you cannot compress well,
send them to [INAUDIBLE].
GUY PODJARNY: Just email
them to Kornel or put them
in DropBox or something,
because the email is going
to be too big, and
compress them before.
No don't
KORNEL LESINSKI: No don't.
PNG is good.
ANN ROBSON: I think
we should seriously
try to get a set of
images that are going
to be our test
benchmark and do this.
Kornel or one of us should take
the responsibility for this.
GUY PODJARNY: So
on that note, let
me use the last
minute we have here
to talk about building
that benchmark.
Who do you think should that
type of effort come from?
Should that be Mozilla, Chrome,
like one of the browser vendors
that's switching the
image formats, doing it?
Should it be a standards--
ILYA GRIGORIK: It's
a moving target.
Ideally, I'd like to have
some sort of a process,
sort of like [INAUDIBLE]
archive, where we just say,
here's the latest set of images.
And perhaps our job is to
define some sort of filters
on all those images, to say
these are the safe ones to use.
Because I also don't
want to freeze that
set, because the web evolves.
All a sudden we are
serving 2X and 3X images.
And perhaps they're at
different algorithms
and do better at high
resolution images.
So that process--
ANN ROBSON: Yeah,
it's interesting.
It's like, what is the
average kind of content also
that is being served
on the internet?
How do we even get that?
But that's important because--
ILYA GRIGORIK: It turns out the
most popular image on the web
is a one by one pixel.
It's like, let's compress that.
ANN ROBSON: Done.
GUY PODJARNY: Well,
I think we're done.
Thank you very much.